demandé pour la première fois de faire une conférence TED Je n'avais pas
réalisé à quel point c'était un honneur Je
ne savais pas ce qu'était une conférence TED et c'est
une chose générationnelle dans mon bureau les
membres les plus âgés du personnel n'avaient aucune idée
et ne le font toujours pas '  t mais la jeune
génération était très étonnée que
je sois choisi pour en faire un et je pense que
c'était mon fils mon fils de 19 ans quand
je lui ai dit que j'allais en faire un il
savait tout sur eux et il a dit wow papa
c'est génial
Les fils de 19 ans ne disent pas ça
très souvent à leurs pères, alors c'est là que j'ai commencé
à le prendre un peu au sérieux, j'ai pensé que
ça devait être quelque chose de gratuit assez
génial, donc le choix du sujet pour aujourd'hui
est au-delà de la propagande, c'est quelque chose
qui est donné  mon parcours, j'ai commencé en
tant que jeune étudiant au collège d'art
de Toronto en apprenant à devenir un spécialiste du marketing en
apprenant à manipuler les consommateurs,
puis j'ai pris un petit choix de carrière et je suis
devenu soldat dans l'
armée canadienne et j'ai suivi ma
formation de commando et sur  prendre sa retraite un  À l'âge de
26 ans, j'ai commencé une nouvelle carrière dans le journalisme
au lieu d'un nouveau magazine et j'ai
couvert les zones de guerre
depuis lors, donc bien sûr être
proche de l'action, voir
comment la propagande est utilisée et en être
très conscient  c'est un choix pour
le sujet d'aujourd'hui maintenant avant d'aller au-delà de la
propagande, nous devrions au moins définir
ce qu'est la propagande et dans sa
forme positive, la propagande peut être utilisée et est utilisée
pendant les conflits pour maintenir le moral sur
le front intérieur et maintenir le moral des gens
dans un contexte négatif  bien sûr,
il peut être utilisé pour générer des conflits pour
créer de l'hostilité là où certains pourraient ne pas
exister au départ, c'est donc un
aspect très négatif maintenant chaque fois qu'une
crise se développe bien sûr les médias
ont tendance à se rallier très rapidement ils
doivent le faire très tôt  en faisant passer ces
choses au bien contre le mal, le patron contre
eux et les médias semblent
participer volontairement à cela, ils ont presque l'impression
qu'ils ont un rôle à jouer en temps de guerre,
ils vont diminuer le  défaites et
vous savez exagérer les victoires
et nous faire tous avancer comme une pom-pom girl
donc il y a des mots à la mode que les médias
ont qu'ils commencent à insérer dans
diverses histoires tôt nos adversaires
notre équipe a considéré comme des despotes ou des
dictateurs ou ils n'ont pas de gouvernements
ils  avoir des régimes, ce sont juste de petits
mots subtils qui y sont insérés
quiconque est contre une autorité que
nous soutenons dit en Afghanistan qu'ils sont des
insurgés et qu'ils ne peuvent faire aucun droit à ces
gens il n'y a aucune
qualité rédemptrice à leur sujet c'est une fois qu'il est
décidé qu'ils sont  fait, ils sont méchants,
ils sont dans le camp eux dans le camp américain,
ils ont de la chance parce que nous les appelons un
roi ou un président, ils ont des
administrations et si quelqu'un descend dans
la rue contre une autorité que nous,
nous n'aimons pas, ils  'sont considérés comme des
manifestants ou des manifestants même
s'ils ont des casques de gourdins et
parfois des armes et cela est
apparu en 2011 avec la crise en Libye
parce que les gens en Libye  s'est soulevé très tôt et a pris les
armes contre le président Mouammar Kadhafi
, puis il semblait qu'il
allait prendre le dessus et à
ce moment-là, parce que l'Occident se
rangeait du côté des nouveaux rebelles, ils ont
reçu un mandat de l'ONU pour faire respecter une interdiction de vol
zone L'OTAN a reçu ce mandat de
protéger les civils, c'était leur mandat,
eh bien, l'
OTAN ne voulait pas simplement protéger les
civils, ils voulaient aider
Mouammar Kadhafi, alors pour faire cela pour
contourner cette petite petite marge de manœuvre,
ils ont trouvé le terme
civils armés  donc les Libyens qui étaient des rebelles
qui avaient toutes sortes d'armes et certains
d'entre eux venaient de l'extérieur de la
Libye ont été qualifiés de civils armés,
ce qui a ensuite donné à l'OTAN le mandat de faire
ce qu'ils voulaient pour protéger ces
gars parce que c'est ce qu'on leur a donné
les choses donc c'est une façon pour eux d'utiliser des
mots et d'utiliser des phrases qui n'ont aucun
sens si vous prenez des armes vous
savez dans une guerre vous êtes un combattant d'autres
choses qui sont utilisées sont des phrases  s
qui sont jetés là-bas, en d'autres termes,
tout ce qui est fait ou comploté
contre nous pour nous faire du mal est un crime de guerre
et une grande partie de cela devient très
disproportionnée l'un des cas que
j'utiliserai pour illustrer cela est celui de l'
époque  en 2002, un jeune de 15 ans Omar
Khadr d'accord il était un garçon afghan canadien
il était dans un village afghan quand
al-qaïda a été attaqué il était là
avec eux mais ils ont été attaqués par
des soldats américains
pendant cette bataille son frère a été
tué il  lui-même a été abattu trois fois
et quand ils ont jeté une grenade dans la
pièce où il se trouvait, il a renvoyé la grenade
et cela a tué un soldat américain et en a
blessé un autre, il a ensuite été
emmené en captivité et après 12 ans,
il a avoué avoir commis un
crime de guerre également  exagéré et utilisé surutilisé
est l'expression arme de destruction massive
normalement ce serait l'utilisation d'une
bombe nucléaire l'utilisation massive d'
armes chimiques ou d'un agent biologique contre
la population urbaine quelque chose quelque part  C'est
énorme maintenant pour vous montrer à quel point c'est
ridicule l'expression arme de destruction massive a
été utilisée quand c'était Richard Reid alias
le bombardier de chaussures en décembre 2001, il a
essayé d'obtenir 10 onces d'explosif plastique à
bord d'un avion dans sa chaussure
dans les talons de  sa chaussure, il a été arrêté,
il n'avait même pas de détonateur, ils l'
ont emmené en garde à vue et il
passe maintenant le reste de sa vie en prison
parce qu'il a plaidé coupable de possession d'une
arme de destruction massive un
peu exagéré là-dessus pour quoi
il avait en fait inversé le fait que lorsque cela
nous est arrivé lorsque l'Amérique a voulu envahir l'
Irak en 2003, ils ont fait la fausse affirmation selon
laquelle Saddam Hussein possédait de véritables
armes de destruction massive, ils ont invoqué
une allégation de légitime défense, mais ils devaient y
aller et il allait détruire le  monde
s'ils ne l'ont pas dit, ils ont envahi l'
Irak au cours de cette invasion
et de l'occupation de 10 ans qui a suivi
et du conflit qui a continué des centaines
de milliers de civils irakiens  pas seulement
par les mains des Américains, mais par une
violence de faction interne, des centaines de milliers
de citoyens irakiens ont été tués,
personne n'a jamais qualifié de crime de guerre,
c'était un dommage collatéral, nous avons juste utilisé une
phrase pour le jeter là-bas, peu
importe l'échelle.  personne n'en a été
accusé du fait qu'ils ont
falsifié la revendication d'armes de
destruction massive maintenant dans les tout premiers stades
de cette campagne lorsqu'ils sont entrés et ont
attaqué l'Irak, ils ont lancé un énorme
bombardement aérien des principales villes
d'Irak en utilisant de vraies armes de
destruction massive bombes de 500 kilogrammes sur la
ville énormes explosions et le secrétaire américain à la
Défense Donald Rumsfeld a en fait déclaré
que c'était la tactique de choc et de crainte
qu'ils employaient et il a dit
qu'ils le faisaient délibérément pour
saper la volonté du peuple irakien
de résister une fois  l'invasion a commencé donc
en d'autres termes c'est bien de terroriser
les civils tant que c'est nous qui
terrorisons maintenant l'armée vient par
sa propagande  d'une manière très honnête
parce que cela va à l'encontre de la nature humaine de
prendre une autre vie ce n'est pas dans la nature humaine
de tuer un autre être humain nous avons une
empathie naturelle en tant qu'espèce je pense que
vous réalisez tous si vous voyez un enfant
tomber de son scooter et gratter  son genou nous
grimaçons si nous voyons le sang de quelqu'un d'autre
parfois les gens s'évanouissent chaque gars dans la
pièce sait s'il voit un gars prendre l'un
des nads que tout le monde sait ce que cela
pourrait ressentir ça ne doit pas être
lui nous ressentons sa douleur alors  que pour surmonter
cela, faites-nous confiance pour aller là-bas et
tuer réellement les soldats apprennent à l'
école de combat et dans le camp d'entraînement que nous
devons déshumaniser l'ennemi, donc
nous n'allons pas en guerre contre les gens, nous allons
en guerre contre les Krauts Japs pince les pentes
gooks, ce sont tous des termes vraiment offensants
, mais ils ont été utilisés en temps de guerre, même
utilisés dans les bandes dessinées pour faire entrer les gens à l'intérieur,
c'était quelque chose qui était juste
généralement appelé et nous avons accepté cela
et nous pensons aussi maintenant les entendre comme
je le dis quand pe  Les gens grincent des dents, c'est
comme si nous voulions croire que nous sommes
une société beaucoup plus sensible maintenant, en
particulier au Canada où nous sommes beaucoup
plus ouverts et beaucoup plus cosmopolites,
que nous ne ferions pas des choses telles que nous
n'y penserions pas parce que  de la
nature du travail et parce que les
gens essaient de faire du mal à nos soldats dans
divers endroits, ils ont toujours ce genre
de mentalité et un exemple que je
donnerai aussi montre parfois quand nous
livrons ces insultes et elles viennent
avec eux indique assez souvent à
quel point nous sommes ignorants de l'autre culture dans
laquelle nous nous engageons en 2003 lorsque les
Américains sont allés en Irak l'une des
premières choses qu'ils ont faites a été de
démanteler les forces de sécurité en Irak
chaque policier chaque agent de la circulation chaque
soldat  a été désarmé et envoyé sur son chemin
il n'y avait pas de loi et d'ordre tout le monde
était dans les rues
il n'y avait pas de services publics en fonctionnement J'étais
là à cette époque c'était le monde
devenu fou L'anarchie est descendue comme une folle comme
vous pouvez  imaginez que les gens ont commencé à piller
tout ce qu'ils pouvaient trouver là-bas,
ils subvenaient à leurs familles
en prenant à une autre famille là-bas,
nous sommes donc des soldats américains qui ne sont
jamais allés en Irak, ils y arrivent et leur
première impression du peuple irakien est qu'il
y a ces gens  sont des pillards
qu'ils sont ils sont des voleurs je veux dire qu'ils sont
dans les rues c'est ce qu'ils font
c'est tout ce qu'ils voient quand le mandat
est finalement venu pour les Américains d'
emménager maintenant à ce moment-là ils l'avaient vu dans
le centre  de Bagdad, il y a une grande
statue pour la dédier à Ali Baba et
aux quarante voleurs plus de preuve que ces
gens célèbrent le vol alors quand les
Américains sortaient et qu'ils
détenaient des gens sur une scène une scène de crime les
arrêtait ils le feraient à travers les
interprètes diraient  es-tu Ali Baba
et les Irakiens diraient volontiers oui oui
tu sais chérie
Ali Baba je veux dire moi Ali Baba et les
Américains les menotteraient et les
emmèneraient et ils étaient confus quant à la
raison pour laquelle le  Vous admettiez si
volontiers un crime et les Irakiens étaient tout aussi
perplexes parce qu'ils savaient que leur fable
Ali Baba n'était pas le voleur, c'était le gars
qui a tué les voleurs, il était le héros,
mais parce qu'ils ne savaient pas qu'il y
avait  une énorme déconnexion là-bas, donc ce qui était
un terme péjoratif était en fait un terme
favorable Les Canadiens sont coupables de la
même manière en Afghanistan le terme qu'ils ont
utilisé pour décrire tous les Afghans est Hajis Je
déteste le dire mais c'est comme ça qu'ils les
appellent maintenant ils utilisent le terme Haji  ceci
comment avez-vous que cela découle
du moment où nos gars sont allés pour la première fois dans les
villages et rencontraient les habitants,
ils disaient que vous savez faire avancer le
chef du village et presque à chaque
fois qu'il serait présenté comme Haji
Abdul Wardak ou  haji muhammad Ghul ou
quels que soient les prénoms qui prennent vraiment des
notes,
nos gars ont commencé à croire que
tout le monde en Afghanistan portait le
prénom Hajji
maintenant, ils peuvent être pardonnés pour cela, mais
quiconque comprend l'Islam
la religion sait que le ha ha G est un
titre qui est accordé à quelqu'un qui
a fait du Hajj un pèlerinage à La Mecque,
donc les très rares qui arrivent à le faire
et ceux qui rentrent chez eux sont
affectés par leurs villageois locaux et
ils '  sont tenus en haute estime, alors nos
soldats pensaient qu'ils utilisaient un
terme péjoratif alors qu'en fait ils
donnaient à tout le monde un titre indu de
respect et d'honneur, il serait injuste et
imprudent pour moi de me tenir ici donner l'impression
que c'est seulement l'Occident qui est  coupable
de tels préjugés et de la capacité de la
propagande à travailler sur leur
ignorance, je suis dans une position tout à fait unique
car en tant que journaliste, j'ai fini par
passer cinq jours en otage en Irak,
cela n'a pas été mentionné dans l'intro en 2004,
j'ai été pris  captif d'Al-Qaïda en Irak
j'ai été détenu j'ai été battu j'ai été torturé
et à cinq reprises ils m'ont emmené pour
être exécuté
dire  eux, vous êtes
canadiens,
j'ai dit eh bien, vous devez comprendre que
ces coins reculés de l'Irak où ils
m'ont emmené, c'est une enclave turkmène assez
éloignée et leurs enseignements sont
transmis par leurs clercs et ils ont
une haine de l'Occident qui remonte à
les croisades leur terme pour moi à la première
et à la troisième personne était le franc et nous
ne parlons pas franc est un nom c'est le
franc comme dans le vieux français de l'époque où ces
gars faisaient partie des croisés donc
il y avait beaucoup d'écart là-dedans  mais
évidemment quand ils enseignent sur les
croisades nous sommes le mal incarné et
maintenant tout d'un coup nos gars qui
me retiennent captif me détestent mais ils ont
gagné en captivité pendant cette période
assez souvent leur haine se
tournait rapidement vers la curiosité mon collègue était
turc  et elle pouvait leur parler et
ils lui posaient toutes sortes de
questions comme que mange ce singe blanc
que fait-il comme que sait-il
tu sais juste des questions simples mais
comment vit-il et pour  pour eux c'était une
opportunité unique car jusque
là s'il s'en souvient on peut imaginer
les photos des soldats américains
qui étaient en Irak les seuls qu'ils
auraient vus d'autres nord américains
étaient toujours des gilets pare-balles des casques des lunettes
ils ressemblent aux stormtroopers  de
Star Wars, ils se sont essentiellement
déshumanisés au profit des Irakiens et cela leur a
permis de les haïr plus facilement et de
les tuer parce qu'ils ont
démonté ça maintenant, tout d'un coup, mes ravisseurs en
ont un, il est hors de son armure, donc
c'est comme un  tortue hors de sa coquille et
je suis très humain, donc cela a changé
un peu la dynamique, aucun National
Geographic n'a fait de film sur cette
épreuve, c'est l'un de leurs épisodes enfermés à l'
étranger et ils ont capturé les
montagnes russes d'émotions ce qui s'est passé
comme moi et  mon collègue a été
transféré de groupe en groupe et nous
avons été attaqués et chaque fois que nous avons été
donnés à un nouveau groupe, tout a
recommencé la personne qui nous a pris en charge m'a vu  n
moi dans un cas en particulier il a vu le
visage de l'invasion les américains il
n'a fait que me transpercer des yeux il
voulait me tuer il m'a dit qu'il voulait
me tuer il m'a dit qu'il allait
me décapiter et il voulait il  a creusé une
tombe ce jour-là c'est un acteur qui joue
le rôle mais c'est assez proche hehe ce
gars je veux dire qu'il voulait vraiment tuer et la
nuit au coucher du soleil je devais les
emmener dans ma tombe et être décapité alors que
le soleil commençait à partir  vers le bas, j'ai en fait
marché sous la menace d'une arme vers cette tombe
lorsque nos précédents ravisseurs sont revenus et que
les gars s'appelaient le chef était
mubashir il est venu il a outrepassé le bourreau il
a mis une cale avec sa longue dispute
les gars voulaient toujours me tuer mais il
était  dit non alors ils ont décidé de passer tous
cette nuit ensemble dans le désert afin
que deux groupes restent ensemble nous étions
là et nous avons dîné ce soir-là
qu'ils ont apporté une couverture pour
la première fois Mubasher est venu
s'asseoir avec moi et mon  collègue et il avait
salut  s dîner avec nous et zana up la fille,
le collègue m'a expliqué que dans
les enseignements du Coran si un guerrier
rompt le pain avec un autre guerrier, il
ne peut pas se suicider par la suite,
donc c'était une clé, il y a un énorme soulagement pour
moi parce que ce gars  était assis à ma
table, ce qui était énervant, c'est que
le bourreau qui est toujours là n'est
pas venu nous rejoindre alors il était toujours il y
avait encore un vide là-bas et cette nuit-là nous
n'avions que des lits en métal dans le désert
nous n'avions pas de couvertures non  matelas non pas de
couverture nous sommes sous les étoiles et il faisait
très froid comme dans le désert
et à un moment donné je me suis réveillé avec un frisson
déplacé en essayant de mettre mon
manteau Pullman et de tourner le dos au vent et j'ai
réalisé que  l'exécution était de
garde il s'est levé de son poste est venu
j'ai fait semblant d'être encore endormi il s'est tenu
au-dessus de moi et je savais qu'il était là un
peu puis il s'est éloigné et je
me suis senti soulagé et je il est revenu et il
était  debout là encore j'ai senti un wei  ème
sensation sur mes épaules et sur mon
corps et j'ai réalisé qu'il était allé me chercher
une couverture et il a mis une couverture sur mon
collègue aussi donc cet homme qui quelques
heures plus tôt c'est toujours la même
nuit voulait me trancher la gorge
du coup il avait dépassé que c'est l'
ignorance qui engendre la peur il n'était
plus ignorant il me voyait comme un humain et
parfois je dois admettre que quand on
parle de conflits c'est que l'ignorance
est un bonheur et que pour les militaires ils
ne peuvent pas s'attarder dessus  leurs erreurs ils
ne peuvent pas se concentrer là-dessus et ils ne le font pas nous
étions au bal du corps des marines l'année dernière
à Ottawa c'est là que tout le
détachement de marine se réunit
ils étaient pleins de médailles coupes de cheveux jarhead
ils sont tous là ils rayonnent dans une
bande vidéo  de leur commandant de la marine
et de ses remarques de clôture et ils se
souvenaient des Marines, vous n'avez jamais perdu une
bataille, vous n'avez jamais perdu une guerre et ils ont
tous sauté et crié Semper Fi et
j'étais assis là à penser bien Vietnam
Afghanistan Irak genre de oh  quatre trois
mais pourquoi laisser la vérité faire obstacle
à ce que vous voulez croire en ce moment
pour le Canada, nous venons également de traverser
un engagement de 12 ans en Afghanistan et
nous savons que nous n'avons pas gagné cette guerre même
la commémoration que nous  avait le 9 mai a été
appelé un jour d'honneur parce que ce n'était pas
un défilé de la victoire et dans ce conflit au
début, le gouvernement voit l'ordre du jour Le
premier ministre Harper, lorsque nous avons commencé à
faire des victimes, est allé là-bas,
il a dit que le Canada ne coupe pas et ne court pas
c'est devenu le fait que si vous
ne soutenez pas la mission et que vous ne
soutenez pas bien les troupes, ce n'est pas
tout à fait vrai, mais personne ne veut être
antipatriotique, personne ne veut manquer de respect à
ceux qui servent en danger au
nom de notre pays, donc le  les médias se sont à peu
près autocensurés, ils n'ont pas contesté
la mission et c'est là qu'ils ont
laissé tomber le soldat parce que c'est le travail de l'
armée d'accepter l'autorité
sans poser de questions, mais c'est le travail des médias de
remettre en question l'autorité sans
exception et en aucun cas  t en respectant ce
principe, les médias n'ont pas bien compris
quelqu'un au début de ce conflit a
dit écoutez est-ce vraiment la meilleure
solution dans ce pays ravagé par 30
ans de guerre civile et de violence entre
pays appauvri avec une
main-d'œuvre largement analphabète est le  solution pour
nous d'envoyer des dizaines de milliers de
soldats entraînés pour former des centaines de
milliers de jeunes Afghans au maniement des
armes parce que c'est ce que nous avons fait maintenant, étant
donné que c'était une zone de guerre, nous avons donc envoyé l'
armée et lui avons demandé quelle
devrait être la solution  et l'armée
a proposé une solution militaire, de toute évidence, nous
devions créer un environnement sécurisé
avant de pouvoir aller de l'avant si nous avions
envoyé un responsable de la santé, ils auraient pu
dire, regardez ces gens doivent être en
bonne santé avant de pouvoir leur donner une
éducation avant qu'ils puissent apprendre  construire
avant de pouvoir passer à un ingénieur
aurait dit regardez nous devons construire des
hôpitaux dans les écoles afin que nous puissions commencer à
fournir des soins de santé et à enseigner, etc. le
thé  cher aurait probablement dit regarde, il
ne pleut que trois jours par an, nous pouvons
enseigner aux enfants sous un arbre, commençons à les
éduquer
, puis devenons en bonne santé et apprenons à
construire, etc., nous avons
opté pour l'option militaire et, par conséquent, à ce jour en
Afghanistan  les soldats sont payés trois
fois ce que les enseignants sont payés, nous avons donc en
fait handicapé le
programme d'alphabétisation que nous étions si enthousiastes et tant
promus, car aujourd'hui encore, la
plupart des jeunes hommes prennent une arme à feu et
sont formés à l'utiliser plutôt qu'à
apprendre à lire et à écrire ou même
comme la majorité des recrues de la police
sont des analphabètes de seize
ans, je manque de temps en
conclusion, nous avons été au lieu de
construire des ponts, nous avons construit des
murs et renforcé ces murs de
propagande chaque fois qu'il y a  une
situation de crise développant la clé devrait être l'
éducation et le dialogue au lieu de cela,
nous suivons une voie par laquelle nous fermons des
ambassades et expulsons des diplomates, puis
nous créons un vo d'information  id dans ce
vide vient la propagande et c'est pourquoi nous
devons aller au-delà de la propagande Merci